there guys thanks for tuning in
something a little bit different for you
today i've got a casual chat with a
special guest who needs no introduction
i know this because you guys have been
requesting this for a long time it's
none other than jack's blade for those
of you who don't know what we've been
doing jack's blade is a fellow fitness
youtuber who also does videos inspired
by superheroes and anime etc he also has
a bunch of other useful content on his
channel and he's just a really
knowledgeable and friendly and
charismatic guy and he makes fantastic
content one thing that really stands out
when i'm watching jax's stuff is that
it's really clear that he's trained a
lot of people he's been training for a
long time he's got a lot of wisdom a lot
of really unique and good ideas several
of which i've borrowed from my own
workouts so he's got a lot to talk about
and i think i'm gonna really enjoy it
this has been coming an awfully long
time this is actually part two of a much
longer chat and you can find part one
over on his channel there we just kind
of hit it off discussing a lot of the
stuff that we have in common because
there's not that many people in this
niche within a niche and turns out that
we experience a lot of the same things
when it comes to trying to work around
our filming training in public etc so we
had a great chat and if you're
interested in a kind of a behind the
scenes look at how this stuff is done
then i highly recommend checking it out
and subscribe to his channel whilst
you're over there in this one we talked
about diet and body fat percentage
combining different training modalities
all the usual stuff that you love here
and it was great getting his perspective
this is not the last time that we'll be
doing something like this so stay tuned
and this also isn't the only video i'm
gonna be uploading this week i do have
one coming either tomorrow or the
weekend so stay tuned for that one as
well either way i hope you enjoy this
one and booya on i mean bye for now
what
in case we say something awesome and
then no no
well it's us so it's all going to be
awesome exactly have you accidentally
injured yourself when doing like
literally all the time
let me be like oh thank you so much
is nuts
i tried it
no no no no no that is so valid though
because like there are some times where
it's just like i have to do i have to
film this workout but i also have to get
my own workout yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
it is it is so true though like it is
one of those situations where you like
you talk to
uh like you said jim bro mate and it's
just like so we're going to work on our
pecs and back and stuff like that and
it's just like oh well are we going to
do anything you know for flexibility or
cardiovascular conditioning or anything
like that it's like nope
yeah exactly we want to get cardio we
lift faster that's what we do
no no okay we need to work on these
together it's just like because i what's
funny is i know so many people in their
like you know 30s and stuff like that
and they're acting like yeah so back in
my prime house able to do this and yeah
like you are 32 years old like what are
you talking about you like if you do
this because like i always tell people
like um i honestly do think this because
i feel i'm 31 right now so i feel better
than i did when i was 24 just because
i'm taking better care of like all these
yes
smarter smarter care yeah smarter care
like so so much smarter care like you
like like we're both like in our 30s
right now so it's just like we like
people are like chicken yeah they're
just like yeah you're
this one day this is gonna happen it's
just like nope feel good we both feel we
both feel great really look at my i
really want to be like 60 doing this and
people just like yeah
why how are you still doing this like
but yeah like you i think what you're
going to say like if you just i really
believe if you keep doing it then you
don't lose it and like obviously some
changes are gonna happen like when you
get super old you're gonna produce less
testosterone you're gonna have like
slightly smaller muscles but if you
maintain the mobility and stuff like
you'll still be able to move great and
there are loads of examples of people
who can like like jackie chan yeah he's
like
he's doing a lot like there's a lot more
like wire work and stuff now but like
he's i don't know how old he is now like
i think i remember like 10 years ago
everyone's like he can't carry on doing
this like he's too old it's like 10
years later he's like he can't carry on
doing this like and obviously he's also
someone who's like injured himself like
countless times yeah and he's done stuff
where it's just like bruh you are a pro
because like like oh like when you see
like every stunt and he breaks down
every injury like oh yeah i almost died
here i almost did this yeah i was just
like respect for like that's my like
aspiration by the way like in terms of
like the person i think is the closest
to a superhero i think was with jackie
chan like right when he was a bit
younger like i was saying like in he'd
have to be in your primer a little bit a
little bit younger back when he could
run on grass
like to me like he was like strong he
was agile like like and he moved with
like timing and rhythm like that like to
me power yeah it was amazing like that's
kind of what as a kid like that's one of
the main things that really got me into
all of this was i was like i love i
loved spider-man like and all this and
then i saw jackie chan and i'm like
he moves like them like you can do it he
can do it he can jump off walls he's got
the ability he like he hits every
freaking like you know uh physical
component of fitness like with the
flexibility of strength endurance like
everything he's just jumping back and
forth he had like a good bod when he was
younger too and stuff like that yeah
yeah he did yeah he was such an
inspiration like drunken master and like
you know uh what was that uh meals on
wheels
yeah wheels on meals because wheels on
meals
with freaking benny and him having that
fight that was just that one oh
that's when you see like he was like a
proper fighter as well like he wasn't
just a goofy stunt guy like he could
also like really fight when he put his
mind to it
that was beautiful yeah that was like
that
epic fight scene
and also
before that when he climbs into the
tower and he's using those sticks and
doing like the like i like is that yeah
is this it can't be cgi because they
didn't have cgi back then like
right right now it's just like there's
so much stuff you see with jackie that's
just like
how though like how do you physically
learn the fact that you could do this
like him jumping through little holes or
something like how did you learn that
like you know in rush hour too and he
jumps through the little hole in the
cash yeah
like how do you learn to make yourself
small enough to fit through that quickly
like how did you not clip your nose off
on that thing like right it's just like
it's like those very old because i know
he was inspired by like the very old um
yeah
than that yeah buster keaton yes that's
his name thank you where he like they
were just doing such insane features
like if you make one mistake you're dead
like yeah that's the key thing and
jackie just mastered that like he
mastered that beautifully and i like i
always love his story of like how he
like met bruce lee and stuff like that
like that like side guy like who just
attacks him and bruce lee like you know
whaps him with the stick and then breaks
his neck and stuff like that and then
after it was over like bruce lee came
over and it's like are you okay i'm so
sorry
oh and he acted like he was hurt he's
just like oh yeah he's getting more
attention yeah
he's so great i love jackie
i i reckon that's like one of the
reasons like both our channels we we do
like talk about hybrid stuff like mixing
uh like mobility and weight training and
stuff because um like because we're
inspired by superheroes and that like
yeah obviously they they move in these
ways that are like superhuman and so
like it's not enough to just be strong
because like that's you know it's cool
to be really strong but like if you
really want to be like a superhero you
gotta be fast as well and like you know
you gotta have your cardio yeah exactly
yeah that is like one of the biggest
things i always like like i because the
superhero thing was we were both in love
with is just uh
i'm such a proponent of like training
cardio with people like saying like it's
important to keep your heart up because
like there's just been like this
demonization i've seen of like cardio
like oh yeah don't do cardio zap your
gains don't do this it's after your
hands i'm just like but like what if
you're in a situation where you got to
run away from like something like this
or yeah like survive a zombie apocalypse
like i'm just saying like if you lose a
little bit of gains and it means that
you can actually do something for longer
than two minutes like it's probably
worth it in it like that's the thing
that i don't like we're saying people be
competitive like that's something that's
been mad at me people get like so set on
like lifting the biggest weight that
they'll like sacrifice everything else
and it's just like competition or ego or
whatever it's like people like you can't
do everything all at once because you
won't be the best at any one thing and
it's like you're probably not going to
be the best at any one thing anyway so
like why don't you make yourself just
really good at loads of stuff
exactly it's it's like it is it's like
honestly like you can't be the best of
anything unless you're like literally a
superhuman like it's just like freaking
like no uh
uh usain bolt would dust like half thor
the freaking strong man but then half
the would outlift him and it's just like
they're not doing it and then they would
both lose to like you know michael
phelps in the pool so it's like yeah
it's just it doesn't matter like you
can't be the best at everything but also
like what you're talking about the
competition thing is something i find so
fascinating
about like uh this thing because i've
i'm very open about like you know
talking about like hey the mental
process is like not only important for
like you to get more intelligent but
also you to like stay you know healthy
up here because this is you like you
gotta focus on it because like i see so
many things along the line of where
people are constantly just like like you
said in con competition with each other
when people just have different goals
like it's just like oh
uh like it's just like you're never
gonna have the perfect physique to every
single person like no matter what you do
because like all right let's say you're
like a big dude like you got some big
brolic muscles you're ripped all that
stuff it's just like what are people
gonna say oh he's on steroids i don't
care if he's natty he's on steroids he's
not actually in jb he cheated to get
that way and even if you are natty a
bunch of people just to be like yep
steroids whatever yeah and it's um
if you're a big strong man oh i'm big
strong man i'm super like strong i can
like bench press the earth or something
like that she's like yeah but you're not
lean you're not
it doesn't count it doesn't count that
way and then it's just like okay let's
go over to the the other side so let's
say you're like a leaner frame who's
like a boxer or a calisthenic person
it's just like yeah but they got baby
arms though they're not that strong
they're tiny they're not yeah
and it's like
what are you talking about it's like
like i've seen boxers who are just like
you know like 155 pounds but they could
lay some power yeah yeah and people are
just like they're skinny though they're
lame just like and then go over to like
the midsection
and it's just like you see someone who's
big but not too big but definitely not
small and like they're just like they're
not they're decent size people go like
that muscle group is lagging this needs
to be yeah he's working so it's just
like don't work out for the approval of
the people work out for yourself because
you're never going to be perfect to
everyone so just like find that like
whatever you want for yourself don't
focus on because it's just like it's so
petty what people do it's just like are
you serious especially on the internet
on the internet because there's a
billion people with a billion different
like opinions and like you wrote
anything yeah
it's like a it's like i think um i
forgot who said i think bill bursa but i
was like it's like a beauty pageant for
like fitness people it's just like oh
well he has 12 abs you only have eight
so
i'm not going to listen to you you're
right
it's like what are you talking about
it's like the knowledge is great it's
like ugh or like um
this thing because i one thing i really
love that you do adam is like you talk
about how uh promoting um abs at a
higher body fat percentage because it's
just like so many people are trying to
be like oh i want to be like six or five
percent body fat it's like i don't think
you do i really don't think there's no
that is it it sucks it's like i want a
burger i want this it's just like okay i
want to
look this ripped and i want to look like
this character it's just like you
realize if you look like like where is
it let me i have a character yeah here
let me take this buff pikachu or
something like that you look like this
buff pikachu with like i don't know how
much body fat percentage of this mass or
something like that do you know how much
everything else on your body is just
going to be like
i look so awesome but i feel like [ __ ]
so i was just like
you don't want to maintain that you do
not want to make a day that
sucks like i i think like every time
like um i'm uh like super lean i was
like i i look cool and i'll take a bunch
of selfies and be like yeah i'm dope but
it's just like i
not in the best head space for this i
prefer like higher body fat percentage
and just like yeah i like i weight train
the abs to make them pop more so it's
just like yeah you know do that stuff
and core work of course yeah yeah
because just like you know why are you
doing it like people are like oh yeah
but like you say yeah you're stronger
you've got too much body fat on you and
it's like yeah but
so like like
fuel yeah you feel it's not going to
massively affect your like speed and
stuff like i don't know is it worth like
really have been miserable with your
diet for like you know years and years
and years just to like maintain a couple
percentage less and you can have decent
abs with a slightly higher body fat
because i always say like people are
like oh you know it's just about body
fat but i always say now like do a
really hard abs workout and you'll see
your abs actually stick through more so
like if your abs are stronger then you
can get away with it with a little bit
more body fat and they still look decent
and then you know if you want to do a
good photo shoot then you just you know
you change the lighting and whatever
like yeah there's a lighting
quote unquote like there's so many like
secrets you learned like because like um
like
because like first let's talk about like
chris evans right chris evans when he
was in captain america like uh that body
yeah he's not super low body fat and he
looks great
he looks great like what they did was
like because i you just like you see the
way they do it because like we both know
this stuff like inside now but like some
people who watch it are just like wow he
looks like a competitive bodybuilder
because he's lean it's just like
i mean
that's what he's he's he's he is a very
lean guy and he does have some nice
muscle mass but it's not like that
because like all he did was when you see
him non pumped up on captain america one
and he's like oh yeah he he's lean he's
got a nice build to him but like he
clearly is pumped up they sh
got the lighting right and they also
come from a baby yeah yeah yeah so he
looks like uh oh god i'm just joked out
of my mind and it's just like it's a
it's a
it's that old um body illusion trick of
just being lean like it really like i've
talked to so many people out there where
they just see like abs and that
automatically means like oh my god
they're as big as ronnie
yeah
but okay
yeah
but it's the point of like making like
fitness like healthy and if you've got
to like sacrifice like
too much to get there then it's like no
longer healthy and functional is it
because now you're sort of right yeah
sort of feeling worse like you say but
also you're not enjoying life as much
and you know there are ways that you can
sort of have your cake and eat it like
you're like people always say like what
what diet do you follow like and stuff
like that and it's like well i just eat
a bit more protein because i work out
and like i'm quite sensible with
sometimes i'll do a fast like if i
notice that i've got like
too too soft then i'll be like yeah
exactly intermittent fasting days which
makes like a really big difference to me
really quickly like i think i'm just
that's that's sort of how my metabolism
works but the rest of the time like i
just like yeah all right i won't eat the
extra chips today or like if i'm bulking
a bit i'm like i will eat the extra
chips a day and that's about it right
that's right
i don't do anything crazy and i eat a
lot of stews and a lot of like because
i'm like pop polish so i made like lots
of goulash and things and i like my
bolognese and things as well just like
hearty hearty meats like you bulk up on
hearty meats like as a kid i think i got
strongest mom which is feeding me with
all these like
beast jews
like ash and gwampki and stuff and
that's like meat wrapped in cabbage so
just eating all this stuff and yeah you
don't need to do anything crazy and like
that's right maybe you're not going to
get to six percent body fat but like you
can't maintain six percent body fat
forever you certainly shouldn't it's not
fun like it and you're trying to just
insane yeah yeah and even then like
right weird so yeah just so like find
the comfortable weight that you're happy
with and i would say if you're gaining
weight then you know just a bit less
than you're currently eating and if
you're losing weight and you want to not
eat a bit more than you're currently
eating like don't even need to do a
calculation you just know roughly what
you normally eat and so right scale it
back until you sort of start to see the
trends that you want to see
right exactly no because it's just like
like the way i always tell people is
just like you know like don't hyper
focus on the scale just like look at the
mirror and then like what i'm doing now
is just like you know i'm a tape measure
just like just measure your waist like
see how that is for you and stuff like
that because like i know for me uh i i
pretty much are in the same boat as you
adam where it's just like
for my type of diet quote unquote diet i
just think of it more as a lifestyle
thing because it's something i enjoy
doing it's just um like you said get
enough protein in throughout the day and
then just um i i like to do it like a
85-15 thing where it's just like oh
majority of the foods like because i'll
break up my foods into
um
this is uh like medicinal type food
where it's like this is just going to
make me like give all the body it's
works or something that makes me feel
better and then i'll have um food which
is like nutritional food but i know
seasoning so it doesn't taste bad so i
was like oh yeah this nutritional food
and then like the last 15 is just like
you know maybe i do want some ice cream
cake maybe i do want some cold so maybe
i want some like you know a cheeseburger
that's greasy and unhealthy or something
like that it's just like yeah i i'm able
to have that and then it's just like you
know it's the dosage that affects you
exactly yeah calorie intake really
similar to like my phosphate i think
it's i always think it's more important
that you get the good stuff than it is
that you don't get the bad stuff and
that's the bad stuff is like poison but
like exactly
make sure you're getting all your
nutrients and everything like i think
that's super important because otherwise
you know you feel tired you don't
recover as well like hey i'm sort of
making sure i'm getting enough magnesium
lately and i really genuinely think
that's like increased my testosterone a
little bit because i feel like i look
slightly more muscular when i when i
take more magnesium but like that's
probably that's probably just unique to
me because i probably don't have enough
in my diet naturally or whatever but
like make sure you're getting all your
micronutrients and then don't eat too
much and then
do what you want
exactly like do what you want and stuff
like that like i always like um there
was this point i heard a long time ago
where was just like you know eating bad
once a week won't hurt you just like
eating good once a week won't help you
so it's what you do consistently it
counts and so like for me it's just like
primarily just like i just want to have
a balanced lifestyle where it's like you
know i can just you know enjoy my life
because i
i think it was uh because i think we've
all gone through like the the chicken
broccoli like phase where it's just like
yeah what am i doing with my life
for like a week yeah yeah it's just like
what am i doing with my life this is
awful so it's just like it's like social
as well like you know if my wife comes
home and she will like i'd be like oh
you want to have some some chocolates
i'm not going to be like no you have the
chocolates i'm going to eat this you
know
chickpeas chicken yeah because
it's not only you know no fun but it's
also you know like she's doesn't like
it's nice to have chocolates with
someone in it like right
yeah no that is a hundred percent it
like that's what i was actually going to
as well because it's just like you're
going out with friends who like you care
for and they love seeing you and it's
just like i don't want to like limit my
lifestyle because we're only here for a
short amount of time so it's just like
yeah i might as well just enjoy the time
i have i was just like yeah so uh what
are we what's on the menu okay burger
and cheesecake okay sure whatever let's
do this and then if you're really
worried you can just do a little bit of
extra cardio and like that can be fun
like um i just do like a bit of beat
saber or something yes yeah yes yes beat
saber or like um what was it the thrall
of the fight game those games oh yeah
through the fight i've been doing that
one i do the myths because i'm
like if you go on to the oh no it's not
the fight which one is it it's the other
one um knockout legends because the
fight is brilliant you need a lot of
space don't you but yeah but knockout
legends i think it's called that it's
got like a training mode so you can do
like it's got like um a mix we'll be
like you know hook hook jab jab and i
like that because it's you know good for
the brain as well because i'm like hook
hook jab what and then he hits you and
you're like right he's like try harder
so like that's really good as well
that's i'm going to try that out ever
because like i i like i've just been
obsessed with like thrill of the fight
that is one of those ones where she's
like i can't go oh you get sweaty didn't
i don't you no no you got like like i
will make it seem like a real fight like
i'll put it up to like 12 rounds but the
opponent's thing like this and it's just
like okay this is good the only thing i
will say like sometimes i realize like
okay my my right hook is just insane
because like i i just like piece them
off like i just hit myself right there
so right there
yeah exactly it's bad yeah
that might just exploded into a million
pieces yeah it's just like there
but i i love that game but like um like
you said that is so true cause like
sometimes
it's just like am i am i gonna eat like
a pig today yeah probably i am so i'm
just like let me i'll like either set up
a thing where i like i'll do like a
burpee circuit where like i'll just be
like oh yeah let me like do uh you know
a countdown of burpees that's the easy
simple way or i'll get like my jump rope
and then just do a quick jump rope step
like and they're super quick and easy
isn't it as well it doesn't have to be
like even a full workout that's yeah i
do exactly the same sort of thing
especially as a parent like it's so much
easier to fit stuff in i do three sets
of 100 push-ups and i do like i don't
know if you've seen i do like like not
full range of motion i do like no no i
that was genius i want to say this to
you adam because like for years everyone
was telling me like that is stupid you
shouldn't do that but i was like but i
feel such a better pump than this i was
like no no that scientifically let me
show you why that's wrong
yeah that's why i stopped for a while
and i'm like no because i i know from
experience from myself and from my mates
like who i told to do it like this works
so i'm going to find out why it works
i'm going to come back and because i was
really scared in that video because
everyone's going to be like yeah
nonsense you've got to do full range of
motion you've got to be like do it nice
and slow and like there's a place in the
time for that but like a this is a form
of like metabolic conditioning because
you're going fast enough like your heart
rate gets going and yeah like like you
said yeah you get a real muscle pump and
like
maybe you don't have the strength as
much from this position but when you're
gonna push anything from that position
anyways like you might go up to someone
and try and push them like that would
you you're starting from say like yeah
it's it's in my opinion it's fine and
like i've honestly that's like
you know how we say like we do a little
bit of extra cardio to like burn a few
calories that's what i do if i notice
that my muscles are getting a bit softer
i'm like right for a while now i'm going
to do like these super high rep
bad form push-ups and the same thing for
like body weight volumes or pull-ups
something yeah something pulling and
like it just does it for me and same
with squats for the legs like you can
just pump out a load and it just swells
i think it's just the metabolic buildup
and yeah i genuinely think it's been
easier for me to maintain a decent
physique for all these years because as
a kid i just did hundreds and hundreds
of push-ups you call them um anime god
makers don't you
yeah yeah yeah
every anime characters yeah
but it turns out they were right
yeah i know it's so true because like no
i because i was so grateful when i
watched that video of yours adam because
i was just like okay and let me see this
like partial things and i was just like
okay and he was you were just breaking
down like okay why you should do
partials because i was like i used to do
this so too often so i need to hear what
adam's because he is
like explaining it and i was just like
no no yeah like i prefer like hell i can
get like a freaking 10 pound dumbbell
and then just like go here yeah not go
full range and it's just like i'm
feeling it build up i'm feeling a nice
pump and it's just like this is a great
workout like i love it like it's my i
love like having like your um super
functional routine because of course i
gotta like show my support for you with
that stuff i was like i like i was
checking out i was just like well let me
try one of these workouts and i was like
i love how one of them is like that sort
of thing because like yeah
yeah this is a bit brilliant
they're brutal yeah it's like no it's
like it's a lot of suffering that turns
out to be very rewarding that's how i
look at it and i i personally find that
if i can feel it working then i'm a bit
it's more fun because if you can't feel
anything because a lot of people like
don't train to fail you don't train to
pain and i agree that you don't
necessarily have to but for me
personally if i train and i don't feel
anything and i'm like it's not as
rewarding like whereas if i can really
feel it i love that feeling you get at
the end of the day where you've done a
good workout early that day and you sit
down and you're like oh and your muscles
and now you just get to eat and it feels
like your body is just regenerating
what's all the food you feel like you
deserve it
yeah yeah yeah
i agree so much with that because like
um i know there's this whole thing about
like how uh you get a better workout
when you um rest a longer like two three
minutes and it's just like yeah it's
true but like for me i just feel like
i'm like twiddling my thumbs i really
love uh because i am in love with
circuits i think it's just from like the
mma and also the conditioning i'm such a
cardio bunny i love like oh okay and my
muscles are being pumped but also like
i'm having a short uh rest period
because it's getting my heart rate up
and i'll get my vo2 max i do the exact
same thing again my recipes are like 30
seconds usually and i i don't do many
reps but i'm going to failure quicker
and you know yeah again like there are
some there's plenty of arguments for
doing that like you can fatigue more
motor units that way so you can use up
bigger ones that otherwise wouldn't have
been involved in those like lighter
weights and stuff so like there's reason
to do it and yeah i'm the exact same as
you if i'm like two minutes i'm just
like what am i gonna do for two minutes
and i don't like to do another one
yeah it's way better and like when
sometimes like if i move where i
literally can't do it unless i wait for
two minutes i hate that i'm just like
yeah what can i do in the meantime yeah
exactly it's just like oh well i guess
i'm just gonna walk away and do that and
it's just like it makes you like bit it
makes you like get the results and just
like just like yeah but it's boring and
i want to enjoy what i'm doing yeah
exactly yeah
i was speaking to um a guy called andrew
tracy he's really knowledgeable and he
was saying like how so many people who
get into like
the the entry um sort of point for
fitness for so many people is sports and
so they're like that's one of the
reasons that they're like hyper
competitive and i think they have to do
things in a certain way or is he saying
he said that like the sort of stuff that
we do is like
we're using superheroes as the entry
point so it's like a bit more hopefully
welcoming and also like a bit less
competitive because it's not about
building yourself up to a sport it's
just like doing it for the sake of it
kind of thing and like hopefully it
makes it interesting to more people and
yeah i think like all that stuff applies
because you know it's we're coming at it
from a slightly different angle than a
lot of people who like you know got to
be the best or got to be better at
football or whatever like we're just
sort of like yeah you know enjoy it sort
of
move like a superhero if you want to
yeah exactly no that's what i love about
our channels too is because the fact is
just like yeah like if you want to move
like these characters you want to be
able to move like um do all these
dynamic things then these are various
ways you can go about doing that or
various things you can learn so you can
like you know better yourself to do that
because like you said it is a thing of
like um just uh someone who could be
like you know not the most popular but
they're very curious and they love the
stuff and they see that and it's just
like whatever because like i know for me
as a kid like i always tell this story
like i was i used to be this chubby uh
bullied anime fanboy who used to get
made fun of all that stuff and like you
know beat up and all that stuff so i was
like oh i would come home and i would
see goku just on tv and he would like
work out like i think that was the thing
that inspired us because he was working
out to get stronger but before it was
like with superman it was like i'm in
the yellow sun i'm i'm just this yeah
yeah you weren't born like it so you
can't do it something yeah exactly when
spiderman was like i got bit so of
course i'm gonna be this stronger it's
yeah so like uh i love i both love
superman and spider-man to death but
like you know with like watching like
goku is like he was like working out and
getting there and i was just like that
is that is just oh my god i don't know i
could do that i could do that so like i
just it motivated me and so like i
wanted to bring that like sort of like
motivation to other people because it's
like yeah you know these characters are
several ones you could do and this was
like oh wow that is that's awesome it's
like yeah i love that whole sort of yeah
thing and that's it
okay and the world of fitness is so like
sort of alpha and like and like the
grind like you see all these people like
talking about like get up at 4am and
like eat
this many calories and if you don't then
you're just wasting your life and why
would you do anything you're wasting
your life yeah exactly and i think like
you and i we're not like that and we're
saying like you know it doesn't matter
that much it's just sort of getting into
shape and having fun and like
that's like hopefully what i think maybe
makes us a bit different because we're
not we're not like yeah i get the
impression you're not like the sort of
grind type guy like neither of us nasty
chicken
like oh god no i used to be no no i had
like this thing where like uh i was
saying like if i if myself now met
myself in my early 20s then it would
just be like that scene in like uh um
end game when captain america meets his
younger self where it's just like you
need to wake up at four what are you
doing with your life i'm in the gym
doing this just like know shut this over
you like that
i was i used to be like that and when i
was younger but then like i you know you
life you grow up you learn various
things you humbly and it's just like you
know you just your mentality changes
stuff like that because like i remember
right now
i'm at the point where it's like hey
guys like if you want to do this uh to
better your life it is going to make it
so much better but again like it's your
choice like you can choose to it just
enhances your life i think that and that
welcomes more people in who otherwise
would have been like put off by it
because like yeah you know if you're not
the kind of person who responds to being
shouted at by a by a like a big navy guy
like then like and there's nothing wrong
with that if that's like what you
respond to then that's great but at the
same time like you know if you're
someone who like responds better to like
superheroes and sort of not necessarily
going mad just doing a little bit then i
think that's a really good thing
doesn't have to be like you're either
fat and lazy or you're like the
strongest person like this crazy
discipline right like you can just like
do it do as much as you want and so have
fun with it kind of thing and i think
that's really cool yeah
and that's why i like um also i love the
stuff that you put out adam too because
like you know not necessarily like super
cereal stuff but like that's great too
but it's like um when you just talk
about like exercises that like no one
else is like really talk about it's just
like oh do your hindu squats do hindu
push-ups like stuff like that or like do
handstands crawl everywhere and stuff
like that and it's just like these
things that like pretty much there are a
lot of things we used to do as like as
kids and it's just like oh we just kind
of outgrow them but it's like no it
makes it more fun than just yeah you
don't have to outgrow them like
yeah kids like say i watch my daughter
and she just does like perfect squats
straight down to the ground she can like
arm dislocates she like holds her hand
together and do them right behind her
back and like round to her butt and like
and it's not she's not trained for it
it's just it's like we've trained out of
it like she just like if you just keep
moving and enjoying yourself then you
maintain these sorts of things it's just
right like it's just like being a kid
was just so much fun because it's like
you have like a rubber body basically
it's like oh i broke my bone oh it'll be
healed in like two weeks whatever it's
just like yeah and also you didn't
always hurt yourself did it like as a
kid like you
i think that's that's one good thing
about hurting yourself though is like
you've had your injuries and i've had
mine and it actually makes you a little
bit better advising people on how to
avoid them because like we can empathize
with that situation and we know what we
did to get there so like how we fixed it
so that hopefully makes us better
coaches on the whole yeah exactly no
exactly like for me like if i see
someone like doing like a dead lift like
with formula i'm like no no no no we
need to fix this get this back right
that's wrong
that can go i've seen that i've seen
that go wrong so many times because like
you know where the person like tries to
say hey your form is a bit off and then
they'll just be like well i'm bigger
than you so you don't know anything and
then like okay and then like literally
like a few seconds later crack and it's
just like oh see the drop and just like
tried to save you he's just like the ego
got you so
been there hurt my back doing a doing
like a clean one time which was sucky
yeah no no i've done that with uh
overhead squats like overhead squats
because when you're doing it you gotta
get in the position and it's like oh
what happened what happened all right
again that's like a mobility challenge
that you don't even realize until you
get down there
exactly it's just like okay i need to
say something but like i hate those
moments when you feel it like we talked
about that earlier where it feels like
you feel it and it's just like oh i need
like a aspirin i need like an ibuprofen
or something like i need something to
heal my back right now or something like
that yeah yeah yeah and you're just like
you're like how bad is it like how long
am i gonna have to have off like what
have we done
not that long ago i should put on like
some of my videos a clip of me running
and jumping and catching a tree branch
and this one time i did it and i slipped
off and i like crashed into this bush it
was also bush full of stinging nettles
and brambles so like my back was like
crump like really hard
and i was actually all right but i'm
just lying there like
am i all right like all right yeah back
like because this will be bad if i have
like
right no no no you're just getting up
like
i can move this is looking good like
right
you know because that happens so much
like too especially because it's just
like there's so many things i want to do
where i was like oh i wanted to go to a
skate park with my friend but it's like
if i bust my ass if i i won't know if
i'm like broken for like a while because
it's just like i i can't tell am i
regenerating or is this just oh my god
did i effort myself why did i do this
why did you stupid ass do this
you know
i did it that doesn't mean you have to
do it like be really careful in my video
i'm like but you just like jumped out of
a tree
right so i guess i was like you just did
it it's my job there it's a little bit
different
also like that's the other thing like
i'm trying to like you you don't want to
um sort of encourage people to do things
that dangerous you also like don't want
to go too far the other way and like
molly coddle them because the other day
like i was doing climbing in the tree
and like because it's a great workout
and funny and then i was like but should
i show this because like what someone
copies me and they fall and then it's my
fault and i'm like yeah but little kids
climb trees and like so am i gonna say
like don't climb a tree because you
might hurt yourself but at the same time
like
every little kid does it and it's fine
and the only reason it's dangerous is
because you don't do it like it's really
hard line to walk and like some people
go too far the other way and they're
like you know this person didn't say
that they had to absorb the impact when
they landed it's like we can't say every
single thing and also right most people
know to bend their knees when they land
like
right like you don't want to like
really baby them like yeah no no that is
a hundred percent encourage them as a
result
right exactly because there is like a
fine line of balance between like you
know coddling and then just being like
it's just man up stop being a little bit
you know something like that so it's
just like there is a spine line because
like and i try to always just hit
straight in the middle because it's just
like all right
look this is going to be challenging
you're going to be worked but you will
feel better from it but here's the thing
i will say just be careful with this but
if you choose to do that
you chose to do that like i specifically
said
be careful but just you know if you want
to do it by all means but again don't
get mad at me if you choose to do
something that like you know that is
saying like i i see this all the time
where people will get mad it's just like
hey i was doing this workout and i hurt
myself this way and it was like like
none of my stuff recently but everything
like that i was just like but the person
right here at this link said this right
at this time stamp that you don't have
to do this and to be careful you chose
to do it yourself
yeah yeah yeah it's it's tricky and at
the same time you don't be like
be super careful like this can happen
this can happen this can happen because
they're like well i won't do it right
and you see that i'm like right like
press steps people like don't do a press
about this you're going to injure
yourself don't do it like this because
you're going to injure yourself and like
yeah you can get like shoulder problems
with a press up if you've got your arms
completely fled but then like that's
like if you're like up here and like
it's also you know individual to you and
like if your arms aren't completely by
your sides like that's okay so i'm
always like be careful with this but
also it doesn't really matter that much
like
you're not getting into the injury
yourself just fyi so like be aware of it
but don't be afraid of it because that's
ultimately not the best thing in the
world but exactly exactly because it's
just like you want to encourage and then
like you know give them those stepping
stones to move up and stuff like that
without giving them like uh like yeah
i'm just going to push you off the cliff
and see if you can climb back up like
that
you'll figure it out
yeah